Rogers place in Edmonton Alberta Canada
for those without GPS that's where it is
UFC 240 at Rogers place coming up on
Saturday Ticketmaster dot C a for
Ticketmaster is available for that you
can you can watching the old
pay-per-view Dana White UFC president
here on the Rich Eisen show how are you
Dana I'm great how are you ready okay so
I don't know if this is the same thing
as beer is it ten percent more potent up
there when you fight up the bands up
there or incredible you know we we get
up to Canada a handful of times a year
so you know it's fun great atmosphere
okay what do you what do you I will give
you the floor on what you're looking
forward to seeing most at UFC 240 sir
I'll give you the floor well max
Holloway tried to move up to 155 pounds
unsuccessfully wanted to be one of a
handful of guys to win two belts on two
different weight classes now he's back
in his real way going against the legend
Frankie Edgar and I expect first of all
both guys fight the exact same way they
come forward they throw punches until
they wear out their opponent and
eventually finish them so I I expect an
absolute war in this fight okay and then
obviously Chris cyborgs taken on Felicia
Spencer in the featherweight bout right
there you've got a bona fide superstar
in Amanda Nunez how does these cyborgs
outcome play into your immediate plans
for Amanda
and what to do with you know I've been
trying to get cyborg to take the rematch
with her in cyborg doesn't want it so it
really doesn't unless she fights
Saturday night and changes her mind
it really doesn't so Amanda Nunez is
there she's one of the best to ever do
it she's the best female fighter ever
and I would love to do that fight again
with cyborg but I don't blame cyborg for
not wanting to do it and why is that
because I'm Heather Nunez is nasty
Amanda Nunez you know the women fighting
has become very popular and you know
there's been so many great female fights
the difference between Amanda Nunez and
everybody else is most women don't knock
each other out I'm
Nunez knocks women out not just you know
rank fighters she knocks out the very
best in the world
okay and now moving to the men's side of
things you know khabib has become a
global superstar and he'll return after
his post connor suspension in september
assuming he wins that fight what do you
do next with him daniel ight well it's a
very interesting division because you
have a Beebe
you have Tony Ferguson Conor McGregor
Donald Cerrone he's in the mich it mix
just engage I mean there's just so many
unbelievable fights in that weight class
and you know babe keeps talking about
fighting George st. Pierre again st.
Pierre retired but when Saint Pierre
retired he retired basically saying I
won't if I could fight khabib so there's
so many different crazy interesting
things that we can do in that weight
class what about khabib Conor I mean
that that obviously would be monumental
in the mind's eye of so many people in
your fan bases well Dana is there any
any possibility of that it would be a
massive fight and it's absolutely
possible yes okay where where are we on
that front
where I mean real-time record yeah I
think McGregor is going to come back the
beginning of next year so realistically
all these guys are looking at September
to see what happens with a Beebe and
Poirier
after that fight plays out I think
there's gonna be a lot of movement going
on okay and is it safe to assume that
Brock has done and that we're moving on
from less we are okay yes we are okay so
then there's been a lot of talk about
the Jones at Daniel Cormier 3 and
obviously DC's got a big fight with
steep a coming up and I saw him in
person for a billions episode when we
were all ringside for that and he is he
is a monster as we all know where does
that whole situation stand in your
estimation Dana yeah it's funny because
you know not just the fact that these
two don't like each other but it's the
fact that they're two of the best ever I
mean they're literally Daniel Cormier
and John Jones are two of the greatest
fighters to
live and I just think that people no
matter is that John Jones was already
won twice I think the people want to see
that fight and I think that people want
to see it in heavyweight Horomia has
never lost a fight at heavyweight and
he's only lost to John Jones at light
heavyweight yeah I had John Jones on a
few weeks ago he didn't seem too
interested in that whole concept of head
oh I know yeah and neither does Cormier
Cormier wants to fight him at 205 he's
like not enough he beat me there that's
where I want to beat him I don't want
there to be any perceived advantage
because we were in every way
okay so best guess it for me how do you
how do you how do you see that all
playing out I mean do you think that we
would see Jones dc-3 if obviously
nothing goes awry for DC against steep a
Dana yeah perfectly said he's got a
tough fight coming up against TPA who is
highly motivated to get his title back
we'll see how that thing plays out and
if he wins yeah I would have to say yes
I think we would see it Jones Cormier
three okay and then Nate Diaz is
returning after a three-year lay off to
fight Anthony Pettis in mid-august right
here in our backyard in Anaheim
California what are you expecting to see
from him Dana it's an incredible
ridiculous fight between two really
talented guys that have wanted a fight
the Anthony Pettis is wanted to fight
the Diaz brothers for a long time he's
gonna get his opportunity at Nate and
it's gonna be fun that's gonna be a very
fun fight right here in Anaheim
California what does the ESPN
relationship mean for you guys what is
it done for UFC Dan it's been on it's
been unbelievable you know it obviously
if you're involved in sports I don't
care what sport you're involved in
everybody wants to eventually get the
ESPN right and you know what it'll mean
to your business and then but you don't
really know until you're in it I've been
in business with ESPN for six and a half
months the impact that this company is
out on my business already is
unbelievable they're the biggest of the
baddest they're the best and it's been
an incredible ride and I'm in six and a
half months of a seven-year deal yeah
I'm very excited yeah just TAS the
halfway through just you one of his you
said of a seven-year deal obviously in a
few minutes I have left with
you're a big fight game individual we
saw Pacquiao just beat Thurman over the
weekend do you think we would you want
to see Mayweather Pacquiao one more time
they're going at it right now and you
understand you're well versed in the the
chatter world and what that might mean
in terms of reality what do you think
about that Dana why so the fight should
have happened many many years ago in the
prime it didn't when it did happen Manny
Pacquiao had a bad shoulder I think that
the fight does have to happen again
I think they do have to do it again
think the Pacquiao look great the other
night against a real tough kid younger
guy and and yeah it'll happen okay you
think it will happen
and I'll do okay last one flu Thursday
anything anytime there's too much money
involved rich huh bet on it happening
well then then that is that why you
think Connors coming back is that all
you think he's coming back to be on a
fight I think as I go back and forth you
know is he gonna be in the next Guy
Ritchie movie you know that's not
obviously Aladdin but you know what are
we gonna see from him nah but you know
what the connors credit and defense you
don't see Connor running around filming
movies he's not Connor if you look at
his he's in great shape he's staying in
shape he's training and he's playing and
seeing how this thing plays out and
here's what you have to remember about
Connor Connor will come back into
Meccano owns this whiskey company and
they're killing it Connor has nothing
but money but Connor loves to fight this
kid is passionate about fighting and he
will be back and he will fighting and
when's the last time you spoke to him
last week okay
UFC Fight Night in Newark Covington
versus Lawler you've just been talking
about obviously your event in Rogers
place that's on live on ESPN on the
worldwide leader in sports Saturday
August 3rd so you're going from you're
going from Canada to Jersey I love it
man
this is great you're all over the map we
go from Canada New Jersey to Abu Dhabi
to China and in Australia yeah we are
literally all over the map okay when
you're going to Foxborough Massachusetts
Dana because and
you'd like to go there as certainly as
much as possible starting in September
when you're gonna go there you you're in
like 300 million affiliates all over the
country come on man you can travel
around a little bit some of these things
I could know every radio station on
earth and every television network thank
you do you know one in Anaheim it's a
perfectly placed one for sure last one
for you Dana do you how long do you
think Brady's gonna keep at it what do
you think I know that's your team hold
another 20 years listen to me I cannot
explain my love for Brady to you I love
Brady so much this guy's so fun to watch
and I'm such a huge Patriots fan you
know but in all honesty in reality I
think he's got a good two or three left
in him well that's why I brought up
Foxborough to be honest with you not
just because it would be more
geographically sound for me it's just
because I know you're a boxwood no
Foxboro thoughts bananas Oh Dana I'm an
NFL employee I'm not gonna throw on Fox
come on now yeah yeah no I listen we've
talked about doing things that
Foxborough we've talked about doing
Dallas Texas Stadium okay we have talked
about doing Fenway Park and now we're
talking about fights at Raider stadium
to here in Las Vegas so maybe you could
just put actual Raiders in the Octagon
Dana then just combine the whole darn
thing I love it take care of Dana thanks
for the call brother next time next time
here in studio when you're in Los
Angeles I'd love to have you in person
you got UFC president Dana White at Dana
White on Twitter right here on the Rich
Eisen show for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on VR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app